i'll start with you yan there have been
a lot of great world championship
matches over the years if you could
watch one match between any two players
of any era who would you choose
currently i'm watching my match here so
once i'm done with this i will think
magnus
um yeah i think it would be a close race
um
between um
oh you're you're not talking about a
match that has happened or yeah when it
has happened and one that has happened
uh actually the question is if you want
one match between any two players i need
two players uh
yeah okay i'll just um answer
the question that i
what i thought was the question which is
which match in the past um then it would
be a close race uh probably kasparov
carpo from
uh seville uh
closely followed by um
by
alejand capoblanca from winslowes could
you elaborate on why those two are your
favorites those were awesome
very
tightly contested
with um
with greater ideas between
clearly the the best players of their
time
all right well